to my streets appeared to be on the periphery and for the first several days I got the
impression that this direction was predominant. Later on it appeared that I don't think
I could get that good of pattern but that was my first impression for the first couple
The next question is, was there any apparent direction of propagation and could you tell
it was coming from one side to the other for which system would apply?
Number nine, do you say from the left of the right or something like that?
I tried to correlate it but in my case I couldn't really correlate a pattern out of it.
I would think at the time period which we tried to report the street by street flash by flash was represented.
And it was my feeling that it was generally random during that time period and therefore generally
random throughout the time that we were noticing it.
No, I meant could you detect that it was moving from one side to the other old General.
It was moving in a specific...
Oh, I think that's a great specific flash, yes.
Yes.
But you could say it as a travel from one side?
You really think we tried to report it that way.
Yes, yes.
We're going to mess the way.
How do we have to be able to tackle the scheme?
That's going to be very fast, you know.
And that question kind of redundant, then.
Do you believe it?
Was there some character that these flashes that had some aspect of direction?
Were they all the same run-shaped or were they having tail on them?
Well, what I...
Yes, so what I reported as a street was simply that.
Now, maybe the way we determined the direction subconsciously was that it was a ball of light
moving in a direction, leaving a tail.
But I can't say that for sure.
All I reported was a street and I had the impression of it moving from one direction
to the other.
And I reported that direction and I can't clarify it much more than that.
I think they can see this in the darkened room.
But just right.
The idea is to try to see whether this is what you saw or similar to it.
I think you may have liked it up there.
Wow.
Can you see anything?
Yeah, that's what it looked like except it was traveling.
In other words, it started out and it definitely progressed across the field of view.
You have the field of view.
The direction of motion per individual.
What did that look like?
Right.
Yeah, except you're not traveling.
It was traveling.
I know.
You thought it was a bit quite a bit of an easy bridge.
I never had to see two simultaneously either.
Neither did I.
Well, you have two streaks on that.
I never saw that.
At one time you said you saw a semi-ball and shaped thing.
So what?
A semi-ball and shaped object.
This was in the first report.
I never did.
If I reported it, that's what I saw.
But I don't remember it.
Did you see anything that looked like this?
All I'd say is whatever was recorded when I saw.
No, I, you know, we discussed the various shapes prior to flight.
I concentrated pretty hard on trying to see the shapes.
And I think as I reported, no, it was either a streak.
And just a rather simple streak or was a flash.
And rather a simple flash.
Nothing too exotic about it.
And on a more rare one would be maybe just a pinpoint a light for an instant.
And then get the idea of a flash.
So it would just be a pinpoint for a second.
And it would be gone.
But that was that was more rare than the other two.
But by a plane.
I don't remember the distribute.
Yeah.
I mean, you know, like watching an explosion, you know,
just a ball versus just a steady dot, yes.
Was it like this at all?
Can you see that?
No.
I can't see it.
Can't see it.
We're not getting light.
I don't think it's lighting.
Oh, there was something just as you turned it there.
OK, you see that?
I mean, multiple, uh, this one.
OK, that to me would be the pinpoint that I'm describing.
The, uh, the, the eruption or the, the noas we call them would be more of an explosion.
Yeah.
Are there more dots than that?
Well, you've got a very, very bright center and a diffused edge.
I would say that the impression I had was you would have an area like that
indicating a blow up, but the center wasn't predominantly that bright.
But that, that's getting closer to what we would call a rod.
I would refer to as a nova or a flash.
It's not as bright as what I call a nova.
Yeah.
And was your nova?
It's normally like this one.
I'm just pretty quiet.
No, it was, uh, what I called a nova was, was more of a blob that seemed to
start with that and kind of expand more diffused.
Yeah, more diffused as time went on.
Right.
Right of the net.
Yes.
That's what I'm about.
What I call a flash or a star.
Here, here again, you've got too much contrast between the center and the diffused area there,
though.
That's awesome.
Also your time frame that your flash gets too low, it was faster than that.
Am I right?
And what you just said that when you said flash, you really met a star and not a, not a,
a nova.
It would not, but you didn't describe it.
I think I almost didn't use flash and star interchangeable.
That's not true for you.
No, when I flash nova to me were essentially the same thing.
The only distinction I make is that the pinpoint versus an explosion.
Okay.
I think what Stu was calling a pinpoint was about what I'd call a star or a flash.
And a nova to me was a much bigger brighter thing.
Okay.
A couple of quick ones.
First of all, the cabin lighting.
Exactly.
Was it completely dark or was there some instrument lights still on?
Absolutely dark.
Okay.
Well, yeah, there's, you talk about the time period that we ran this quantitative report.
Right.
Completely dark.
Okay.
And did you have your eyes closed?
It's the time where they open in the dark cabin.
Mine was still open.
Yeah, I go.
Even though we had the window shades and I don't want to roll around some of the sun.
When you tell me who knows the piece of white seepage around where we're at that end of time.
So during that time, really, at least I made my eyes closed.
Yeah.
Open otherwise.
And of course, we closed their eyes when it took this flash.
But generally speaking, eyes were open.
No, mine was almost closed all the time.
I was floating down the corner of the LED bay, but I kept my eyes closed because I didn't know when my role
into the sun and I didn't want to pick up any light at all.
Okay.
The next question on the flashlight was when you shine it in your eyes.
What was the approximate duration in each eye about how many seconds?
Well, I just kind of moved across for a five seconds or so.
Five or six seconds.
It hurt.
It hurt, right.
Yeah.
And the next question on still your orientation in the LED.
You said you were looking for plus X is, uh, will you?
Cross.
I was, uh, generally, you know, how you have the three couches and plus X is, uh, I was oriented this way with my head looking face up down in this corner.
So your hand was in the same direction as it would be if you were on the couch.
Yeah.
Yes.
That's it.
Okay.
And the next question is, uh, in almost every case, you did report that it was in one eye.
The other clue is one incident where you guys, uh, both eye.
And my question is, uh, maybe someone redundant, but we absolutely certain that you could distinguish
that it was one eye as opposed to, uh, yeah.
I felt I was getting more in the left than the right.
But in fact, in fact, you're all heavily biased, both the right on the, on the one, on your
approach.
Really?
Very heavily.
Like, like, three or four to one.
Yeah.
I was shorted.
I was biased to the left.
Well, 12 right and six left.
And Al, you had 10 right, four left.
And, uh, of the ones who reported, Steve, you had six right, two left.
And the rest, we had no reports, or both eye.
It was all very heavily bid by us to the right eye.
That's very surprising.
No, well, well, I'm talking about that.
I, it seems to me that, uh, I would get a flash or a streak or whatever the phenomenon
or whatever the shape was.
Simultaneous with somebody else reported.
That's exactly the next question.
Yeah.
We, uh, there were three from listening to the tape, three events in it.
It occurred in, in cases where, uh, different pairs were wrong.
Uh, which were coincidences where I think in one case, uh, uh,
uh, Ed, you said, uh, flash.
And then Al, you said, simultaneous with him.
I have a flash in the whole right eye.
Now, my question would be, uh, when you, when it was simultaneous, was it after he began speaking or wasn't
in fact, uh, it was his words good enough for you to have been a mark on your flash?
Well, certainly with that infraction of the second, I think it was time for things.
Yeah.
A couple of times it happened to me.
It was his mark or whoever the mark it was was good enough.
Okay.
Same here.
And, uh, then the next question is earlier before the session, then when you were describing
some of the subjective observation, you mentioned the, uh, halo as that you'd seen,
that you'd see a flash followed by, uh, as soon as it take his halo off to put it away.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh, the after effects.
Were they, were they present?
Most of the time.
Didn't you see, did you have, um, spiking in, uh, sort of glow afterwards?
Only on what I call the nova or the super, not super nova.
Okay.
I'm sure it's for you, too.
I don't really know so halo effect myself.
I guess I'm not sure what, what we're calling the halo effect.
You mean, I'm at diffused, uh, brightness.
More, more like an after glow.
Did I call any of those?
I sure don't remember it.
No.
Yeah.
I don't think I saw any of those.
Okay.
And, uh, all the other questions we had was, uh, if you want to make any observations
from your ornament?
Uh, it's not, I know that we're no formal periods, but, uh, I mean, just, you know, I thought
about that on the way back.
And, uh, I was, I was so tired that night that I, I really don't remember, uh, seeing any
flashes, but I, I didn't look for any either.
So I, I guess the question would be I, I consciously did not see any, but I sure, that's,
so I wouldn't take that as a data point.
Okay.
And then, uh, the final question that I have is, uh, after our formal sessions, uh,
it was on, it was at about 1.91, the GED, uh, you didn't have sleep period later on.
Do you remember whether you saw any during that sleep period closer in?
It was significant, whether you were inside the magnet diploma.
Yeah.
I don't consciously recall, but I don't really recall if there was any night, except the
the lunar surface that I didn't.
And sometime or another, they saw, you, you definitely, you didn't see any on the
limit.
I just, no, I don't remember about the lunar surface.
Oh, there was precious one to sleep that night.
I don't know.
Okay.
I want to see all the questions right here.
We'd toss the lights for a minute.
Yeah.
So, uh, while you're dousing light, I have one next question.
Did you get the impression that life laces could have been within the cabin,
or definitely within your eye?
Definitely within the eye.
Okay.
Yeah.
I want to get some idea about orientation and, uh, and like the streets.
Did you ever see anything?
No.
I never did.
The, uh, you, you use the, uh, terminology of, uh, six o'clock hours of the clock.
Does that mean to you, uh, when you say six o'clock to the center about how long the
street is that?
That's a hard question to answer.
Uh, if you were visualizing, uh, something about.
So, oh, about the arms length away from you.
How long would you say your longest street was that long?
Did you see my fingers?
I'll show it up.
Let me describe it a different way.
All right.
Give you a, it appeared to me that the things, uh, I would say were three or four
inches away from my, my playing, whatever that means.
And we're a couple ages long.
Tell us about it.
Tell me to call it.
It's way more inches in front of you.
It, uh, it looks like this.
Too long for me.
Two, I guess.
See that one up above?
One up above looks better.
Okay.
I love this.
Uh, probably fairly close.
Yeah.
I'd say it's quite as close as the longest one.
See, I'm not sure what our, what our scale is here.
I, I'd rather say that if I could, if I'd consider whatever it may be, but the field of view
of saying my right eye and take a radius of that, then I'd put a streak at, uh, have about
a half the radius would be the average street.
Half for a little longer.
Um, okay.
Uh, do you think there's a way that you can, you can associate this lane and streak to
what you said to the longer, short, or can you say?
Well, it would depend on how big a circle I want to draw from my field of view.
Uh, I, I, yeah, I saw streaks, uh, that long because, uh, because with my eyes closed, I, I
imagine a rather big field of view here in my eye.
So, uh, yeah, I, I'd, I'd see, I'd see streaks that long.
One time you said you saw, uh, streak's orient in a certain direction.
Do you remember that?
Yes.
The way you had it, bring it on up that way.
And my, my, that too.
Well, I think I had them from several directions and I reported them as moving from one direction
to the other at that time.
There were several levels of it.
But, uh, now, any particular direction up and down?
That too, right?
I didn't notice any, any preferred orientation.
I'm here again.
I think I'd try to express that the, uh, the length of the arc of the flash in terms of
the, of the peripheral field.
And if you're talking about a horizontal peripheral field as big somewhere at the vicinity
of under 50, 160 degrees, then in some, in some cases, the light flashes would go across
as much as, as 50 or 60 degrees of that.
Where's the light flashes broken in the center?
In some cases, they were.
In some cases, I had the feeling it was two dots.
One to be able to follow any other, giving the pressure right to the left and top to bottom
or bottom to top or right.
The point is, you see that the retina is so curved that if you draw a straight line,
you can't get too long, long, you shouldn't be able to get too long a streak with that
breaking out of the retina again.
You know, with, in the final retina, it goes fake like that.
But it has sub-depth, that was about it.
Okay, have you been any longer than that?
Uh, if it just is, is a problem.
Can't hear that.
There were a couple of portions.
Can't hear you.
It should not have been any longer than what I showed you.
If it just went through the retina, it was one track, but it went through a couple of eyes.
And you would have had an impression along the street.
That's why we're interested in caring for it.
I have one more about the cloud that you saw.
This is a new phenomenon, which we hadn't expected.
Did you describe this lightning behind the cloud?
I think it occurred.
I recorded it a couple of times, and it appeared, as I recall, to be down low,
on one eye or the other.
And it was just a diffuse lighting.
Any color.
Quite sober.
If you were out in the country and looking at the horizon,
there was a lightning behind the cloud.
Was it like that?
Except, generally, if you do that, you can see a street behind the cloud.
There was no street.
Give it just a diffuse lighting.
Similarly, I don't know if it gives my little simulate.
That sort of possibility.
When you get out of the corner,
maybe I'm moving it.
I don't want to ask attempts to try to get in the cloud here.
Does light some energy?
Good job.
I am.
The days don't matter.
Was it anything like that?
I didn't see it.
It's a pretty dim cloud right?
I have no dark depth.
I still don't see it.
I'm not seeing anything on it yet.
OK.
But what you're trying to describe is just what we used to call heat lighting.
It's a kid.
OK.
It's a general diffuse light.
Yeah.
You didn't see the relief of the cloud.
No, not necessarily.
You're just a blob of light.
The one final question,
we didn't voice up to your question about
whether you noticed any other sensations
inside of the planet, which was the reason for asking that
was the difference.
It didn't feel any tingling or finding something
or twitching or hearing anything.
The reason for that is if it is an interaction
back in the brain, then there are other senses.
There's a sense of the individual sense
and maybe you can feel something.
You never noticed that.
No, sir.
Didn't know I said anything.
There's two things to think about.
Do you notice your thumb etching
or your lips twitching?
You think of them?
No.
Never look for it either.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You know, these are suggested questions
and the fact that you say no is significant.
You can press on with different parts of the anatomy.
You might get a yes.
That's a great.
It's two biggest cross-sections for you.
You know if there's something significant
with your thumbs or your lips,
maybe you should warn that people to look for that
because I don't know unless it's going to be so obvious
that if you would make a image all over it.
Well, sometimes you might think you should be.
You're very comfortable.
OK.
We're in.
Thanks very much.
I think I said to me yesterday that you really
did provide a enormously improved metadata
on this phenomenon that we've had in many previous months.
It was great.
Well, I would add this to that.
I think that's the way you really have to go
is to take a different trip, set it aside and do it
because otherwise it's so random
and there's many other things going through your mind
that they're in a way of getting quantitative.
How are you?
You did a remarkable job of concentrating on that length of time.
You feel that that was being unreasonable
to actually do that back.
You've gone to sleep.
It's like that.
It's a pretty boring thing to do.
You're sitting there lying watching.
You think we should be the way of doing this sort of thing
on future missions that we should be.
We shouldn't try and do it much more than we tried that to get used
to doing it because there's too much just since they're lying.
They're trying to concentrate.
I think it's not a time period in the flight when they have
anything else to do.
I think it's a reasonable to suggest that.
I don't think I would do it before a sleep bird
or when they're tired or they'll go to sleep on you.
I think lying failed by the time you,
if you talk a little bit pre-flight like we did,
and then you know the phenomena is there
because you're first sleep period
or the first time you get to spacecraft dark
and close your eyes, you're going to see flashes.
So then that sort of sparks your curiosity a little more
than when they say let's settle down
and count them while I think you're agreeable to it.
Come on.
Okay.
Hey, one other comment on that
and I'm not even sure that it's related
but I really think that this is just a general impression
that if I would look at my,
look at say the glow of the wristwatch
or something like that and then close my eyes again,
I'd almost always see a flash
and I tried then to correlate looking at
say a crack through the window shade
or looking at my watch or something
and then closing my eyes
and I really came to the impression
that the two may have been correlated
but I never really looked at it enough to say that for sure
but I think there was a correlation between seeing a light
or something like this and in closing your eyes
and pretty soon you pick up that flash.
That's an important observation.
If the action is directly in the bipolar,
the regular cells, the other segment,
you might expect it to behave the way
electrical phosphates do rather than just from life
which takes dark and action.
What do you think about that in?
I'm not quite sure what your point is.
I was going to make the comment that
with respect to the flashes,
putting flash light in my eyes
did not seem to destroy my dark adaptation.
Now, what that means, I don't know.
Did you do like that?
Yep, that's low.
That fast.
Yep, for some time.
You see when you wiped out some of the nerves?
I wiped out something.
I'm not sure that's true, John.
How long did you do it?
You should wipe it off.
A couple minutes a minute.
A minute?
Back and forth like this.
About five seconds to put track of it.
Something like that.
Yeah, you know where your seeing is.
The reason you think you didn't knock it off
out is because you can still see the flashes.
Well, the cockpit looked different.
Remember, I was doing this eyes open.
And it seemed like what I considered dark adaptation
that I was more dark adapted
that I had dark adapted much sooner after doing that
than I did when we started the experiment.
You don't think it's...
Yeah, yeah.
Sure.
That you would do.
Because you wipe out the comms less for that.
It's just what it's like to do with the tons of light
early in the mouth.
I'd like to make sure that on this dark adaptation
I know during the formal hour or 40 minutes
whatever it was that it was shining the light.
But I don't know whether you picked it up on air to ground
or not.
But I had done that prior to that during one of the sleep periods.
There's just...
You did not have to be dark adapted to see these.
Yeah, I think that's a conclusion.
You're dropping like any scene.
That's a version of every day of life.
There's almost certainly proves that it's not a real life
in your eyes.
You know, in your eyes.
I think there's a direction.
Yeah, but why did it take us so long
when we started the experiment before we saw anything?
It was quite a while.
And yeah, I wiped the light across my eyes
within 30 or 40 seconds.
They were working.
No, I don't take minutes.
Part of 17 minutes.
No response.
Yeah.
But when I did it with the fly slide within 30 or 40 seconds
they were right there.
You said that they were fine.
They seemed fine than they had on previous periods.
Previous times that you've learned them.
But there definitely is a threshold effect
from some sort because you saw a crisis money
during that period of the opportunity.
And I think maybe it's just my guess well,
but not when you didn't see them.
And then you started to see them regularly.
It was just that they seem fine than your expected.
And so I took you a while to get your attention now
to find the ones that you're looking for.
Well, that may be the case except they did
indeed the pure fader in the beginning.
And it wasn't a matter of looking for fader objects.
They were brighter after a while.
And they didn't diminish the brightness when I did fly
slide across my eyes.
They were still just as bright 30 seconds later
they had been before I used fly slide.
And that's why I'm questioning the dark adaptation bit.
Either I didn't wipe the dark adaptation out
or there is something related to dark adaptation
that influences the phenomenon.
I don't understand.
It makes sense.
I bet there are a bound of time period that we did it.
And the few flashes we saw was very surprising to me.
And we talked about this and we commented on it at the time.
Boy, it seemed like you'd wake up during a sleep period
and they're all over the place.
Now here again, maybe I'd lose track of time.
You're laying there in the dark cabin
and maybe it was longer than what I thought.
But it just seemed like there's abundance of flashes.
And I was amazed when it took 17 minutes to see a flash.
I thought at any time that you wanted to close your eyes,
you were going to concentrate on it.
You were going to see these things.
That's why I suggest that you're really on.
So it's time for inside because it is.
That you ran a function for our line concerned
that you tried to do it in a non-pollinated basis
itself at the time.
Plus the fact that I think that each individual
is going to report at different levels of activity too.
I had a feeling there was maybe some little fake things
that I would sort of say that I didn't want to talk about
because I couldn't define it as a flash.
Yeah, I had those too.
I think all times a good idea to do this point
because you're a subjective impression
that is not necessarily right like you felt
that you were looking at the usual moment
and I thought in your right that was wrong.
I mean, you need to get the data real common.
When you go to sleep at night, do you see any of these things?
Most people do see something as they're going to sleep
in a dark room.
They can't sleep right away down here.
I agree with you, though.
I don't know.
Yeah, you've got lights blinking around
and on your eyes if you're getting a real dark room occasionally.
And maybe because we never really concentrated
on looking for this particular type of phenomenon.
These phenomena that you saw were different from the ones that you see once in a while.
Oh, definitely.
A lot more frequent.
Yeah.
I'll add in brightness.
About what?
Rinkers.
Sorry to see.
Yeah.
I guess I'll make a note to see if I've seen
any of those from here on, but I certainly haven't since we've been back.
But here again, and Ed mentioned this, and I agree with him,
but it's another subjective thing that the flashes you see
when you wake up in the middle of the night
as a whole appear to be brighter than the flashes as a whole
during that experiment that we did during the day.
And unlike Al, I was a little reluctant to call
anything except a very positive flash during that time frame.
You know, I want to make really sure that that was indeed a mark
at the time that I called it.
But those that you saw during the, during the middle of the night
appear to be brighter.
And like I said, appear to be more of them.
But here again, you know, you may lay there for an hour
and you think it's five, five, ten minutes or something.
I don't know.
Maybe you lose track of the time.
But it's a subjective thing.
And so one blue flash did anyone else see color?
No.
Wait a minute.
That wasn't blue.
It was a silver, a blue white.
Like a blue diamond.
It was like a blue diamond.
Was that the brightest that you saw?
I don't recall.
It was a brightest note.
Has anybody been hitting the head and seeing stars?
Yeah.
With these anything like that.
I think I've got more cuts and treating all the pain.
No.
When you go to bed tonight, if you, once in the dark room,
if you just knock on your eyeballs, you should see flashes
in the microwave.
Try that to see when they look like the same.
Yeah.
We cry a lot in here.
No.
I'll say, you know, if you can get the next cruise
to fill, you know, it makes a great topic of conversation.
And, you know, during the flight,
you've got nothing else to talk about.
You can talk about light flashes.
So, I think if you get to get to cruise curiosity
around, it's a good deal.
I think the people, the prankery on the subject,
which is built out of such the movie,
some full looks where I'm going to put the thing
and throw it away again.
OK.
It's very much all.
Thank you.
We're OK.
That was looking back in time for you.
I know what we're going to do with this other thing
and what we're going to do, how things are coming,
time-wise, for the internet to do.
There's a lot of job presented.
You know, you know what the date is.
You know what the time is now.
Oh, 731 on Saturday, then.
Oh.
Is that the release timing?
Yeah.
Work on spring and a certain chance.
Somebody said that 21 days ended up on Saturday morning.
Yeah.
I would have been led to believe otherwise, Chuck.
In a deep briefing plan, it says 0,800 to 26th of 5.
It takes us.
We get out to Friday morning.
Yeah.
He called me yesterday.
He called me.
And he called me.
That's how he says.
How did we ever get this memory?
I said, I don't know what you guys said.
No.
Well, the radiation people are here.
We're talking about release and all that kind of business.
Can we get a half on when they're going
to get total body counts?